miami dolphins gave us a little bit of a
surprise at the end of the first week of
free agency will fuller who is still
serving games under a ped suspension
right he's signed to a one-year 10.6
million dollar deal he's a guy who you
said time and again right great speed
great skills can't stay healthy then all
of a sudden he's healthy and we find out
he's got a ped violation my concern is
and hey look hey i'm not the one who got
popped for peds he did my concern is
once he's clean he's going to get hurt
again all the time he's not going to be
able to stay healthy
i'm with you i mean it would it would
make me question the whole situation
there's no doubt about it you know he's
he's a difference maker they're they're
a different they were a different team
in houston when he was on the football
field
but the problem was is as you can see
right here
looking at this graphic i mean it's it's
14 10 7 11 11. you know there's just
it's too in and out of the lineup all
the time and of course the ped thing
always scares me because you know yes i
sit there and go well i don't know has
he been taking pd's the whole time has
he been sneaking by i don't know what he
really is is he going to do it more to
try to stay healthy as he goes forward
that's scary uh but from the pure
football standpoint it was a much needed
nut much needed
guy or or
just a guy who could take the top off
the defense and go deep down in miami
they don't have that you know yeah they
got devante parker and preston williams
they're real good you know 15 to 20 and
underneath and 25 to 30 maybe that but
fuller is the guy who can scare defenses
and make the safeties go back 10 another
10 5 yards and open up the field for tua
and do that and that's where he's
special that way so there's obviously
some risk there with what they're doing
and it's i i mean it's kind of
surprising i think it tells you a lot
even the injured guy like that
people he got 10 million you know juju
smith schuster didn't get that i think
that tells you something too about what
the film looks like between the two and
you know fuller's gonna help that
offense out though no doubt
that really is amazing though to think
that with all those questions red flags
concerns you're right will fuller ends
up with more money than juju smith
schuster but that's what having the
ability to stretch defense
brings
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports